[Music] I hate taking exams, I'm studying today, and he's the
only one who's flirting.
Is this ayakashi? It's
before the exam,
you're nervous, aren't
you?
I have a story for you
Yato-san's new resignation Hahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahaha, we
're still 3 months old, it's me who
wants to cry
Apply in advance This is common
sense What do you think kindly I don't have a fixed address and I'm
unemployed and I'm a god I'm a
jersey guy Is that really true?
I'll stand on top of all gods
Bokeh
[music]
I'm talking
Fast footing to where you're shivering
[applause]
[music]
[applause] You
really quit your spirit
Atsuka I'm a
god, why don't I find something new in front of the company?
It's a god's inn My
boss is
missing Your boss is here, isn't it
People who give their pets such names
Lords, kings, gods,
gods,
even Ami gives dogs painful names What is it
that hurts the leader of Denny's
?  I'm definitely a
Hyakki Yako What's good about VK?
Which one do you think is God?
Hiyori was a secret martial arts fan, wasn't he?
You didn't tell your parents, did you?
If you knew your sadness, I'm sure your mother
would be worthy of it.
[Music]
Someone you love, who you love Ah [Music] Wait, don't run away, sir
[Applause] A
girl
jumped out,
what would you do if you died?
I called an ambulance
[music] It's a
good day,
it's a
sunny day, I'm
glad I woke up.
Well, it's our hospital, so if I let you stay in for a while,
you know,
there are patients who are waiting for autumn
.
Even if the sum is falling down, it's an
advantage I wonder if my consciousness is still not clear, but
I'm tired.
VOICE
[MUSIC]
Can
you hear
the voice
of Higan?
Is it the police or is
it a jersey called God?
Shout out this name and everyone will open their eyes
and come to me
I will become the kind of god that I wish for
And someday in this country, heaven
[laughter]
[music]
It looks like it's going to be the death penalty tonight too This is their
den I don't even have a sense of humor Now it's
long useless
Nora  I'm busy tonight
Your name is
Hiyori
BreathHiyori
I made sure you were safe This is
n't it My
body is
heavy My
consciousness
Mi-chan
Yama-chan I'm okay I'm
glad I'm sorry  If you jump out or something
I'm going
to punish you with
jungle soba.  I
feel like I met someone in the hospital room
[music]
I've been feeling dizzy all day, but
I've been feeling sleepy all
day
.
[Applause]
That's right
When I was chasing this cat, there was
someone in my jersey
.
[Music] I'm
sleepy again,
this smell
.
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm listening to you
.  But this
woman saved me again.
I'm stuck
Why did I die? It's not like I'm dead
.
[Music]
Thank you for making my wish come true.
Finally, it
smells good
. It's not a pervert. It's a god
.
Perhaps because of an accident, the god of death who breathes people's lives, and the pair of sad wishes, so to speak,
you became a person who is in between those two
.
to  They
're the kind of people who stick around and do bad things
.
Maybe the big frog from earlier is also a ghost
I don't really understand,
but you've become a person who often
loses weight So what can
I do to recover?
I'll beat you sesame 500,000 That's a lot of money I'm a god I
wonder if it's decided that it's a fate
Your wish
I've certainly heard
your breath I hope you have a fate
Your
name No matter what
I'll definitely call you [music] You're the owner of a jagged heart
Whatever you give me
hurts
, glaring at everything in the world and
saying that I'm
here
Somebody was laughing If
that person is
that boundary
[music]
Hold it and
don't let go
I
want you to say that you're not alone anymore
As the first step in the Yasogami Mechaka Plan,
I propose the production of Yatomi Koshi's original shouts
.
da
next time
like Toraya Yuki
[music]